[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hermione granger the time
turner
and the absurd amount of coursework that
she was taking on her third year
but more specifically we will be
tackling the question
did it age her time travel is not to be
toyed with
so were there any lasting detrimental
effects a time turner is a magical
device manufactured by the department
of mysteries that is used for time
travel given the potential usefulness of
a time turner
which allows for time travel one might
expect that this technology would have
been used more in the fight against evil
but in reality it was mainly used by
hermione so that she could take on
more coursework in the 1993 school year
mcgonagall gifts the time turner to
hermione
so that she is able to attend additional
classes hermione's immense workload
finally seemed to be getting to her
every night without fail hermione was to
be seen in a corner of the common room
several tables spread with books
arithmancy charts
rune dictionaries diagrams of muggles
lifting heavy objects
and file upon file of extensive notes
she barely spoke to anybody
and snapped when she was interrupted and
on each time turner there is an
inscription which reads as follows
i mark the hours everyone nor have i yet
outrun the sun
my use and value unto you are gauged by
what you have to do
so a time turner allows you to go back
in time but you may be asking
what are the long-term implications of
time travel using a device that allows
you to relive moments in the past
and then jump right back into the future
the answer to this is of course that
your present self
would have aged depending on how long
you went back into the past
if you went five years back in time and
stayed there for six months
when you returned to the present you
would be six months older than you were
before
but everyone else would have remained
the same age this means that for every
minute someone in the present aged
hermione's time traveling self would age
2 minutes so
given that hermione uses a time turner
for a good portion of the school year
how much did she actually age first of
all it's never explicitly stated how
many courses she doubles up on
and we have no information about how
long they were or how long the terms
were
so all we can do is estimate based on
what we do know
in her third year there were 12 possible
classes that she could have been taking
seven core and five elective given
hermione's nature and the fact that she
was in possession of a time travelling
device
let's assume that she took all of them
however it's later revealed that
hermione later drops two classes
divination and muggle studies she
dropped divination because she was not a
fan
and she dropped muggle studies because
she was a muggle born and didn't really
get anything out of the class
however she did attend these classes for
a portion of the year
which means that she did still age quite
a bit we know that the hogwarts school
year begins in september
and ends at the last week of june there
are also approximately two
two-week holidays that occur during the
school year which we need to factor into
this equation
so the hogwarts school year starts on
the 1st of september and ends the last
week of june
with two approximately two week holidays
one in winter for christmas
and one in early spring for easter
during that time september to july is
approximately 43 weeks of classes
however if we deduct the two two weeks
since vacation time
then that leaves us with 39 weeks of
classes in total
hogwarts courses are generally 90
minutes however students have the option
to double up on these courses if they so
desire
making them 180 minutes in total or 3
hours
hermione's regular 10 course schedule
without the addition of divination and
muggle studies would put her at two
courses a day at three hours each
this would mean that she spent
approximately 30 hours per week in class
and this was doable for hermione but
what wasn't doable was trying to
incorporate
additional classes into this already
heavy schedule
if hermione were to have taken
divination and muggle studies for the
entire year
which she didn't in addition to her
regular course load
then she would have taken approximately
six hours of extra courses per week
for a 39-week duration six hours times
39 weeks equals 234 hours
which equals 9.75 days so if hermione
would have done it for a whole year
she would have aged an additional 9.75
days but
she didn't take them for the duration
hermione dropped divination around
easter
which will just round off to april 1st
this means that she took divination for
a total of 30 weeks
if we deduct two weeks of christmas
holidays from this then i think that
it's safe to say
that she would have aged an additional
three hours per week for 28 weeks
84 hours hermione didn't drop muggle
studies until much later in the year
the third week of june this puts the
duration of her muggle studies period
at 42 weeks and if we subtract both the
christmas
and easter holidays were left with 38
weeks this means that she took an
additional three
times 38 hours of coursework in muggle
studies or approximately 114 hours
hermione also spent about 3 hours
helping to save buckbeak
if we add 84 114 and 3 we get 201 hours
which equates to 8.375 days
so at the end of the day hermione
finished the school year a whole 8.375
days older
than her peers which is really nothing
in the grand scheme of things
i may have made a miscalculation
somewhere but i feel like this answer
has got to be at least
somewhat correct what do you guys think
is this something that you ever even
considered
let us know down in the comment section
below until next time
your wizard harry